so last time I spoke a te 380 was a long
time ago and I gave what was probably
the worst talk of my entire life so I
believed I'd been blackballed by III 80
and last Monday morning I was very
surprised that Dennis asked me to fill
in at short notice so this is a slightly
updated version of a talk I gave at
Berkeley's swarm lab last year you can
try the text of that one with links to
the sources at blog PS a child at all if
you search for swarm the slides are
going to be sketchy because when I was
preparing for that talk was when my
second grand daughter arrived so I'm
David Rosenthal and I'm an engineer I'm
about two-thirds of a century old I
won't my first program about half a
century ago in Fortran for an IBM 1401
about a third of a century ago Bob
sproul recruited me for the Andrew
project at Carnegie Mellon and when I
worked on the user interface with james
gosling I've swallowed James the son to
work on window systems both X which you
probably have used if you use linux and
a more interesting but less successful
one called news then I worked on
operating systems with Bill Shannon Rob
Singhal Steve climbin so on more than a
fifth of a century ago I was employee
number four and NVIDIA helping Curtis
preme architect the first chip and then
I was early employee at Victoria a
second company of Jimmy Chang and Dale
ski founders of the company that's now
called tipco one seventh of a century
ago after doing three companies all of
which IP owed I was really burnt out and
I decided to ease myself gradually into
retirement it was a total failure I met
Vicki rush the wife of the late might
wiser the CTO of Xerox PARC she was a
librarian at Steph still is a librarian
at Stanford and had been part of the
team which nearly a fifth of a century
ago started Stanford's highwire press
and pioneered the transit
of academic journals from paper to the
web she was also the librarian on the
digital library project in CS so she was
the one who explained to Larry and
Sergey about citation indexes which are
the basis of page rank in the paper
world librarians saw themselves as
having two responsibilities to provide
current scholars with the materials they
needed and to preserve their
accessibility for future scholars they
did this through a massively replicated
loosely coupled fault-tolerant
tamper-evident system of mutually
untrusting but cooperating peers that
had evolved over centuries libraries
purchased copies of books journals
monographs the more popular the work the
more replicas were stored in the system
the storage of each replica was not
particularly reliable librarians put it
in the stacks and let people take them
away most times the replicas came back
but sometimes they had coffee spilled on
them and sometimes they just vanished
damage could be repaired via
interlibrary loan and copy there was a
market for replicas as the number of
replicas of a work decreased the value
of the replicas in this market increased
encouraging librarians to move it to
more secure storage the system resisted
attempts at censorship or a rewriting of
history precisely because it was a
loosely coupled peer-to-peer system
although it was easy to find a replica
it was hard to find all the replicas or
even to know exactly how many of the
were and although it was easy to destroy
an individual replica it was fairly hard
to modify one undetectably so the
transition that stanford started of
academic journals from paper to the web
destroyed two of the pillars of this
system ownership of copies and massive
replication in the excitement of seeing
how much more useful content on the web
was discovers librarians did not think
through
the fundamental implications of this
transition the system that arose meant
that they no longer purchased a copy of
the journal they rented access to the
publishers copy renting satisfied their
responsibility to current scholars but
it couldn't satisfy their responsibility
to future scholars so librarians
concerns reach the mellon Foundation who
funded exploratory work at Stanford and
five other major research libraries and
what can only be described as a serious
failure of systems analysis the other
five libraries each proposed essentially
the same system in which they would take
custody of the journals other libraries
would subscribe to this third-party
archive if they could not get access
from the original publisher and they had
an ax a card subscription to the
third-party archive they could access
the content from that archive none of
these efforts led to a viable system
because they share many fundamental
problems including well first libraries
such as Harvard were reluctant to
outsource a critical function to a
competing libraries such as Yale on the
other hand funders were reluctant to pay
for more than one archive publishers
were reluctant to deliver their content
to a library in order that the library
might make money by republishing their
content to others this made the contract
negotiations necessary to obtain content
from the publishers time-consuming and
expensive and in any case that said the
whole concept of a subscription archive
was not an actual solution to the
problem of having access after you
canceled a subscription it was simply a
second instance of exactly the same
problem so one of the problems that I've
been interested in when I was working at
Sun and then again at vitria was full
tolerance so to computer scientists full
tolerances of solved problem right
Byzantine fault tolerance can prove that
three f +1 replicas sigh can survive f
simultaneous faults to an engineer it's
not a solved problem too obvious
questions are what's the probability
that my system will encounter
f simultaneous faults and how can the
system recover if it does there's a very
good reason why suspension bridges use
stranded cables a solid rod would be
cheaper but the bridge would have
exactly the same unfortunate property as
bft it would work properly up to the
point of failure which would be sudden
catastrophic and impossible to recover
from so I've long thought that the
fundamental challenge facing system
architectures to build systems that fail
gradually progressively and slowly
enough for remedial action to be
effective all the while emitting
alarming noises to attract attention to
impending failure in a post Snowden
world it's perhaps superfluous to say
that these properties are especially
important for failures caused by
external attack or internal subversion
so as Vicki explained the paper library
system to me I came to say two things it
was a system in the physical world that
had a very attractive set of full
tolerance properties and an analog of
the paper system in the web world could
be built that retained those properties
so I got a small grant from Michael lesk
who is then at the NSF and built a
prototype system called locks lots of
copies keep stuff safe modeled on the
paper library system by analogy with the
stacks libraries would run what you can
think of as a persistent web cache with
the web caller which would preload the
cache with the content to which library
subscribe because actually of course
nobody reads the journals the contents
of each cache would never be flushed and
would be monitored by a peer-to-peer
anti entropy protocol any damage
detective would be repaired by the web
analog of inter library copy because the
system was an exact analog of the
existing paper system the copyright
legalities were very simple so the
mellon Foundation and then sun and the
NSF funded the work to throw my
prototype away always a good idea and
build a production-ready system the in
testing part of this started when we
discovered that as usual with my
prototypes the anti entropy protocol had
gaping security holes in it I work with
Mary Baker and some of her students in
CS Petros mani artists memo loose opolis
and TJ Julie we built a real Peter PNG
interview protocol for which we won best
paper at SOS p a tenth of a century ago
the interest in this paper which i'm
trying to no.8 a chuckle once more I'm
trying to inculcate a frame of mind
about the length of time we're talking
about the interest in this paper is that
it shows a system which is albeit in a
restricted area of replication that has
a high probability of failing slowly and
gradually and of generating alarms in
the case of external attack even from a
very powerful adversary it's a true p2p
system with no central control because
that would provide a focus for attack
and it uses three major defensive
techniques it uses effort balancing to
ensure that the computational cost of
requesting a service from a peer exceeds
the computational cost to that pair of
supplying the result if this condition
isn't true in a p2p network the bad guys
can wear the good guys down then it uses
rate limiting to ensure that the rate of
which the bad guy can make bad things
happen can't make the system fail
quickly and it uses lots of copies so
that the anti entropy protocol can work
with samples of the population of copies
randomly sampling the peers for each
operation makes it very hard for the bad
guy to know which peers that are
involved in which operations and makes
it hard for him to manipulate those
operations so recent DDoS attacks such
as the 400 gigabit per second ntp
reflection attack on cloudflare have
made clear the importance of rate
limiting to services such as dns and ntp
now our free open-source peer-to-peer
digital preservation system is in use at
around 150 libraries worldwide the
program has been economically
self-supporting for nearly eight years
using the Red Hat model of free software
paid support in addition to our SOS p
paper the program's published research
into many aspects of digital
preservation the peer-to-peer
architecture of the lock system is in
unusual among digital preservation
systems for a specific reason the goal
of the system was to preserve published
information which one has to assume is
covered by copyright one hour of a good
copyright lawyer will buy a current
prices about 12 terabytes of disk so the
design is oriented towards making
efficient use of lawyers rather than
making efficient use of disk the median
data item in the largest locks network
has copies at around 30 peers so i doubt
that copyright is high on anyone else's
list of design problems you may be wrong
about that but I'm not going to argue
with you so the rest of this talk will
not be about the lock system as such but
about the lessons we've learned in the
last 17 years that are applicable to
everyone who's tried to store in digital
information for the long term the title
of this talk was the question that you
have to keep asking yourself over and
over again as you work with digital
preservation what could possibly go
wrong unfortunately once I started
writing this toolkit rapidly grew far
too long don't expect a comprehensive
list you're just getting edited
lowlights so the first thing to realize
is stuff is going to get lost let's
start by examining the digital
preservation problem in its most
abstract form since 2007 I've been using
the example of a petabyte for a century
think about a bike box into which you
put a petabyte and out of which a
century later you take a petabyte inside
the box that can be whatever you want as
much redundancy whatever media manager
by whatever anti entropy protocols you
want you want to have a fifty percent
chance that every bit is the same when
it comes out
as when it went in now think about every
bit in that petabyte like it's a
radioactive atom which has a very small
probability of flipping at random you've
just specified a half-life for the bits
that half life is about 60 million times
the age of the universe think for a
moment about how you go about
benchmarking a system to show that no
process with a half-life less than 60
million times the age of the universe is
operating inside it it simply isn't
feasible since its scale and for these
lengths of time you're never going to
know that your system is reliable enough
Murphy's Law will guarantee that it
isn't at scale storing realistic amounts
of data for human timescales is an
unsolvable problem some stuff is going
to get lost this shouldn't be a surprise
even in the days of paper stuff got lost
but the essential information to keep
society running to keep science
progressing to keep the populace
entertained is restored very robustly
with many copies on durable somewhat
tamper-evident media in a full tolerant
peer-to-peer geographically an
administrative ly diverse system and
this is no longer true the Internet has
in the interest of reducing costs and
speeding communication removed the
redundancy the durability and the tamper
evidence from the system that holds
society's critical data it's now all on
spinning rust with hopefully at least
one backup on tape covered in rust so a
year and a half ago researchers at
Berkeley co-authored a paper in which
they reported that a rapid succession of
coronal mass ejections sent a pulse of
magnetized plasma barreling into space
and through Earth's orbit had the
eruption come nine days earlier when the
ignition spot on the solar surface was
aimed at earth it would have hit the
planet potentially wreaking havoc with
the electrical glued disabling
satellites and GPS and disrupting aries
increasingly electronic lives a study
last year estimated that the cost of a
solar storm like this could reach two
point six trillion dollars worldwide
and most of the information needed to
recover from such an event exists only
in digital form on magnetic media how
many of you read the science fiction
classic the boating God's I by Larry
Niven than Jerry Pournelle only a few of
you I guess it's really historic now
anyway I yeah right it describes
humanity's first encounter with
intelligent aliens called Mo T's Modi's
reproductive physiology locks their
society into an unending cycle of
overpopulation war societal collapse and
gradual recovery they cannot escape
these cycles the best they can do is to
try and ensure that each collapse starts
from a higher level than the one before
by preserving the record of their
societies knowledge through the collapse
to assist the rise of its successor one
technique they use is museums of their
technology as the next war looms they
wrap the museums in the best defenses
that they have the motives have become
good enough at preserving their
knowledge that the next war will feature
lasers capable of sending light sales to
the nearest stars and the use of
asteroids as weapons so they wrap the
museums in spheres of two liter thick
metal highly polished to reduce the risk
from laser attacks so Larry and Jerry
were writing a third of a century ago
but in the light of current events
they're starting to look uncomfortably
prophetic the problem we face is that
with no collective memory of a societal
collapse no one's willing to pay either
to fend it off or to build the museum's
to pass knowledge to the successor
society okay so one way to express the
what could possibly go wrong question is
to ask against what threats are you
trying to preserve data the threat model
of a digital preservation system is a
very important aspect of the design
which is allows only rarely documented
in 2005 we did document the locks threat
model
unfortunately we didn't consider coronal
mass ejections or societal collapse from
global warming but we did consider we
observed that most discussion of digital
preservation focused on these threats
but if you if we went when we went and
talked to the operators of large data
storage facilities their list of the
likely causes of lost data were quite
different so the more we spend per byte
the safer the bites are going to be
unfortunately this is subject to the law
of diminishing returns each successive 9
of reliability is exponentially more
expensive than the last and we don't
have an unlimited budget so we're going
to have to trade off costs against the
probability of data loss to do this we
need models that predict the cost of
storing data using a given technology
and models to predict the probability of
that technology losing data I've worked
on both kinds of models and I can report
that they're both extremely difficult
there's quite a lot of research from
among others Google Carnegie Mellon
backblaze showing that the failure rates
of storage media in service are much
higher than the rates claimed by the
manufacturer's specifications why is
this for example the blu-ray discs
Facebook is experimenting with for cold
storage claimed a 50-year data life no
one's seen a 50 year old DVD disc so how
do they know the claims are based on a
model of the failure mechanisms and data
from what's called the accelerated life
testing in which batches of media are
subjected to unrealistically high
temperature and humidity the model is
used to extrapolate from these
unrealistic conditions to the conditions
to be encountered in service there are
two problems the conditions in service
typically don't match those are seen by
the models and the models only capture
some of the failure mechanisms
these problems are much worse when we
try to model not just failures of
individual media but of the entire
storage system research has shown that
media failures account to less than half
the failures encountered in service
other components of the systems such as
buses controllers power supplies and so
on contribute the other half but even
component even models that include these
components in exclude many of the
threats we identified from operator
errors to coronal mass ejections even
more of a problem is that the threats
especially the low probability ones are
highly correlated operators are highly
likely to make errors when stressed
coping with say an external attack the
probability of economic failure is
greatly increased by for example insider
abuse it turns out that economics are by
far the largest cause of data failing to
reach future future readers a year ago I
gave a seminar at Berkeley High School
entitled the half empty archive in which
I pulled together the various attempts
to measure how much of the data that
should be archived is actually being
collected by archive and assess that it
was much less than half no one believes
that archiving budgets are going to
double so we can't be confident that the
loss rate from unable to afford to
collect is at least fifty percent this
Dwarfs all other causes of data loss so
we need to think about costs digital
preservation has three cost areas ingest
preservation and dissemination in the
seminar I looked at the prospects for
radical cost decreases in all three but
I assume that the one you're interested
in is storage which should be the main
cost of preservation ah so everyone
knows that if not actually free storage
is so cheap that we can afford to store
everything forever for example Dan olds
at the register comments on an interview
with the co-director of the Wharton
School custom an analytics initiative
dr. Peter fader save at all you might
you never know when it might come in
handy for
future data mining expedition clearly
the value that could be extracted from
the data in the future is nonzero but
even the Big Data zealot believes it's
probably small the reason that the big
data settle it gets away with saying
things like this is because he and his
audience believe that this small value
outweighs the cost of keeping the data
indefinitely and they believe this
because they've lived through a third of
a century of criders law the analog of
Moore's law or four disks cridersville
predicted that the bit density on the
platters of disk drives would more than
double every 18 months leading to a
consistent thirty to forty percent a
year drop in Casper bite thus long-term
storage was effectively free if you
could afford to store something for a
few years you could afford the store it
forever because the cost would have
become negligible so Randall Munroe
points out there in the real world the
exponential growth can't continue
forever it's always the first part of an
s-curve one of the things that most
impressed me about Kirsty of sandwiches
keynote on the aspire project at last
year's fast conference was that their
architecture took it for granted that
Moore's law was in the past kreider's
law is also flattening out so this is a
graph from pretty gupta a student at UC
santa cruz showing that in 2010 even
before the floods in thailand double
dollars per gigabyte overnight the
Kreider curve was flattening currently
disk is about seven times as expensive
as it would have been have the pre 2010
kreider's law continued industry
projections are for ten to twenty
percent a year going forward the red
lines on the graph show that in 2020
disk is now expected to be a hundred to
three hundred times more expensive than
pre-2010 expectations that's a big
number industry projections have a
history of optimism but if we believe
that data grows at IDC is sixty percent
a year
disk density grows IHS I supplies twenty
percent a year and IT budgets are
essentially flat which they are the
annual cost of storing in a decade's
accumulated data is 20 times the the
first-years cost if at the start of the
decade storage is five percent of your
budget at the end it's more than one
hundred percent of your budget so the
Big Data zealot has an affordability
problem it's easy to and we often do
complete criders law which describes the
increase in the areal density of bits on
disk platters with the cost of disk
storage in dollars per gigabyte we wave
our hands and say it roughly map 141
into a decrease in the cost of disk
drives we're not alone in doing this
mark Kreider himself does it so my
co-author Daniel Rosenthal of UC Santa
Cruz no relation has investigated the
relationship between bits per square
inch and dollars per gigabyte over the
last couple of decades over that time it
appears that about three quarters of the
decrease in dollars per gigabyte can be
attributed to the increase in bits per
square inch where do the rest of the
decrease come from I can think of three
possible causes the first is economies
of scale most of the last two decades
the unit shipments of drives have been
increasing leading to lower fixed costs
per dr unfortunately unit shipments of
are currently declining so this effect
has gone into reverse in 2005 mark rider
was quoted as predicting in a few years
the average US consumer will own 10 to
20 disk drives in devices that he uses
regularly but what's in those devices
now is flash the remaining market for
disk is the cloud they're no longer
really a consumer technology the next
thing is manufacturing technology the
technology to build the drives has
improved greatly over the last couple of
decades resulting in lower variable
costs per dr unfortunately the next
generation of
drive technology heat assisted magnetic
recording or hammer has proven to be
extraordinarily hard to manufacture so
this effect has gone into reverse and
the third is vendor margins over the
last couple of decades disk drive
manufacturing was a very competitive
business with numerous competing vendors
this gradually drove margins down and
caused the industry to consolidate
before the thai floods there were only
two major manufacturers left with
margins and the low single digits
unfortunately the lack of competition
and the floods have learned to a major
increase in margins so this effect is
gone into reverse but these factors only
account for a quarter of the missing
costs decrease where did the other three
quarters go so this is a 2008 graph from
Dave Anderson of seagate showing how
what looks like a smooth kreider's lower
curve is actually the superimposition of
a series of s curves one for each
successive technology note how Dave's
graph shows perpendicular magnetic
recording being replaced by hammer
starting in 2009 and no one's yet
shipped hammer drives in volume instead
the increases the industry has recorded
as resorted to stretching PMR by
shingling which increases the density
and helium which increases the number of
platters each technology generation has
to stay in the market long enough to
earn a return on the cost of the
transition from its predecessor there
are two problems the return it needs to
earn is in effect the margin the vendors
enjoy the hilar margins the longer the
technology needs to be in the market to
earn it margins have increased and as
technology advances the easier problems
get solved first so each technology
transition involves solving harder and
harder problems so costs more the
transition from p.m. art a hammer has
turned out to be vastly more expensive
than mean industry expected getting the
laser which heats the the
platter up and the magnetics in the head
assembly to cooperate is very hard and
the transition involves a huge increase
in the production of these lasers and so
on so according to daves our
six-year-old graph we should now be
almost done with hammer and starting the
transition to bit pattern media it's
already clear that the hamlet of BPM
transition will be even more expensive
and that's even more delayed than the
pmr hammered transition so the projected
twenty percent a year Kreider rate is
kind of unlikely to be realized the one
good thing about this if you can call it
that is that it puts off the day when
the technology hits what's called the
superparamagnetic limit this is when
shrinking the magnetic domains means
that they start becoming unstable at the
temperatures encountered inside an
operating disk which are actually quite
warm so about seventy percent of all the
bytes of storage each produced each year
is disk the rest being tape and
solid-state so tape has been the
traditional medium for long-term storage
it's recording technology lags about
eight years behind disk technology so
it's unlikely to run into the problems
plaguing disk for some time we can
expect its relative cost per byte
advantage over disk to grow in the
medium term but tape is losing ground in
the market why is this in the past
access patterns the archived data was
stable it was rarely accessed and
accesses other than integrity checks
with sparse but this is a backwards
looking assessment increasingly as
collections grow and data mining tools
become widely available scholars want
not to read individual documents but to
ask questions of the collection as a
whole providing the compute power and
i/o bandwidth to permit data mining of
collections is much more expensive than
simply providing occasional sparse read
access we can get some idea of the
increasing cost by comparing Amazon's s3
designed for data mining type access
patterns with Amazon's glacier
designed for traditional archival access
s3 is currently at least two and a half
times as expensive an example of this
problem is the Library of Congress
Twitter donated a full feed to the
Library of Congress because by doing
that they got a tax write-off although
the library can afford the considerable
costs of ingesting the full feed with
some help from outside companies the
most they can afford to do with it is to
make two copies on tape they couldn't
afford to satisfy any of the 400
requests from scholars for access to
this collection that they received in
the first year they were doing it
subsequently Twitter issued a call for a
small number of proposals to receive
free data set access but even Twitter
can't support 400 future archives will
need to keep at least one copy of their
content on low latency high bandwidth
storage not take so flash has a lot of
advantages including low power physical
robustness and low access latency and
they've overcome its higher cost per
byte in many markets such as tablets and
servers but there's no possibility of /
replacing discs in the bulk storage
market because that would involve
trebling the number of flash fabs even
if we ignore the lead time to build the
fabs which is about five years the
investment to do so wouldn't pay
dividends everyone understands that
shrinking flash sales much further will
impair their ability to store data
increasing levels in the cell stacking
cells in 3d and increasingly desperate
signal processing in the flash
controller will keep density going for a
little while but not long enough to pay
back the investment in the fabs probably
not more than about five years so there
are many technologies vying to be the
successor to flash and most can
definitely keep scaling beyond the end
of flash providing the semiconductor
industry keeps on its roadmap they all
have significant advantages over flash
in particular their plight
rather than block addressable but
analysis by mark rider and Chang soo Kim
at Carnegie Mellon not encouraging about
the prospects for either flash all the
competing solid-state technologies
beyond the end of this decade that may
actually be out of date with the
announcement of X point by Intel and
micron but X point is being positioned
as a very expensive layer above flash a
low ram it's not it for many years it's
not going to be cheap enough to do
storage on so every few months there's
another press release announcing that
some new quasi immortal medium such as
stone DVDs has solved the problem of
long-term storage but the problem stays
resolutely unsold why is this very
long-lived media are inherently more
expensive and they're a niche market so
they lack economies of scale seagate
could easily make discs with an archival
life but they did a study of the market
for them and discover that no one would
pay the relatively small additional cost
the fundamental problem is that long
live media only makes sense at very low
Kreider rates even if the rate is only
ten percent a year after ten years you
can store the same data in one further
space space in the data center or even
at iron mountain isn't free this is a
powerful incentive to move old media out
if you believe that Kreider rates will
get back to thirty percent a year after
a decade you could store 30 times as
much data in the same space there is one
long term storage medium that might
eventually make sense DNA is very dense
very stable in a shirtsleeve environment
and best of all it's very easy to make
lots of copies to keep stuff safe DNA
sequencing the read cost is improving
far faster of far faster rate than
criders or Moore's Law synthesis right
not so much right now the cost
are far too high about four or five
orders of magnitude too high but if the
improvement continues DNA might
eventually solve the cold storage
problem and yes the-the-the work for
example at embo on this embodies in
Vedic error-correction codes in the in
what they encode in the DNA and they
also use I mean it does it in animal in
cellular things this is not DNA stored
in cells this is DNA stored in in gas
and the the DNA access is always going
to be slow enough that it can't store
the only copy you're not going to be
able to really leave the stuff out it
they kind of random access bandwidths
that you need the reason that the idea
of long live media is kind of this
zombie idea that is impossible to kill
is that it suggests that you can be lazy
and design a system that ignores the
possibilities of failure what it once
forget it you can't media failures are
only one of many many threats to store
data but they're the only one that long
live media address and long media life
does not imply that the media are more
reliable only that their reliability
decreases with time more slowly as we've
seen current media are many orders of
energy too unreliable for the task ahead
even if you could ignore failures it
turns out not to make economic sense as
Brian Wilson CTO of backblaze points out
in their long-term storage environment
double the reliability is only worth one
tenth of one percent cost increase
no this analysis assumes that the drives
fail under warranty one thing the drive
vendors did to improve their margins
after the floods was to reduce the
length of warranties so figures from San
Diego supercomputer center suggest that
media cost is about one-third the
lifecycle cost of storage although
figures from back please suggest a much
higher proportion as a rule of thumb the
research into digital preservation costs
suggests that ingesting the content
costs about half the total life cycle
cost preserving it costs about one-third
and disseminating it costs about 16 so
why are we worrying about a slowing of
the decrease in one ninth of the total
cost well different technologies with
different media service lives involve
spending different amounts of money at
different times during the light of the
data to make apples-to-apples comparison
we need to use discounted cash flow or
its equivalent to compute the endowment
needed for the data this is the capital
sum which deposited with the data and
invested at prevailing interest rates
would be sufficient to cover all the
expenditures needed to store the data
for its life three years ago we built an
economic model of the cost of long-term
storage here it is plotting the
endowment needed for three replicas of
117 terabyte data set to have a
ninety-eight percent chance of not
running out of money over a hundred
years against the Kreider rate assuming
using costs from black players each line
represents a policy of keeping the
driver one two three five years before
replacing them in the past with Kreider
rates in the thirty to forty percent
range we were in the flat up part of the
graph where the precise Kreider rate
wasn't that important
in predicting the long-term costs as
Kreider rates decrease moving towards
the zero on the x axis we move into the
steep part of the graph which has two
effects the endowment needed increases
sharply and it becomes much harder to
predict because it depends strongly on
the precise Kreider rate which are not
going to know the reason to worry is
that the cost of storing data for the
long term depends strongly on the
greater rate if it falls much below
twenty percent which it has everyone's
storage expectations and budgets are
based on their pre-2010 experience and
on a belief that the effect of the
floods was a one-off glitch and the
industry will quickly get back to
historic Kreider rates well it wasn't
and if they won't so consider two
storage systems with the same budget
over a decade one with a loss rate of
zero and the other half as expensive per
byte which loses one percent of its
bites every year clearly you would say
that the cheaper system is I has an
unacceptable loss rate however each year
the cheaper system stores twice as much
and loses one percent of its accumulated
content at the end of the decade the
cheaper system has preserved 1.89 times
as much content at the same cost after
30 years it's preserved more than five
times as much at the same cost adding
each successive 9 of reliability gets
exponentially more expensive how many 9s
do we really need is losing a small
proportion of a large data set really a
problem the canonical example of this is
the internet archive's web collection
ingest by crawling the web is a lossy
process their storage system loses a
tiny fraction of its content every year
access Phi the wayback machine is not
completely reliable yep for us users
archive.org is currently the 150 third
most visited site whereas the Library of
Congress is the 1230 first
for UK users archive.org is currently
the 130 seventh most visited site
whereas the British Library is the too
sour 2,750 second why is this because
the collection was always just a series
of samples of the web the loss is merely
add a small amount of random noise into
the samples but the samples are so huge
that this noise is insignificant this
isn't something about the Internet
Archive it's something about very large
collections of data in the real world
they always have noise questions asked
of them are always statistical in nature
the benefit of doubling the size of the
sample vastly outweighs the cost of a
small amount of added noise in this case
more is better in the short term the
inertia of manufacturing investment
means that things aren't going to change
much bulk data is going to be on disk it
can't compete with other uses for the
higher value space on flash but looking
at the end of the day decade and beyond
we're going to be living in a world of
much lower Kreider rates what does this
mean for storage system architectures
the reason disks have a five-year
service life isn't an accident of
Technology disks are engineered to have
a five-year service life because with a
40-percent Kreider rate is uh neck
anomic to keep the data on the drive to
longer than about five years after five
years the data will take up about eight
percent of the drives replacement at
lower Kreider rates the media whatever
they are will be in service longer that
means that running costs will be a
larger proportion of the total cost it
will be worthwhile to spend more on
purchasing the media to spend less on
running them for years ago in adams
ethan miller and i were inspired by the
foreign paper from Carnegie Mellon to do
an analysis we call dawn durable away
array of wimpy nodes in it we showed
that despite the much higher capital
costs a storage fabric consisting of a
very large number of very small nodes
each with a very low power system on
chip and a small amount of flash memory
would be
with discs the reason was that Dawn's
running costs would be so much lower and
its economic media life somewhat longer
that it would repay the higher initial
investment the more the Kreider rate
slows the better error analysis looks
Dawn's better performance was a bonus to
the extent that successors to flash
behave like Ram and especially if they
can be integrated with the system on
chip they strengthen the case further
with lower costs and an even bigger
performance age so let's sum up and I
hope I've said some things that people
can disagree with expectations for
future storage technologies and costs
were built up during three decades of
extremely rapid cost per byte decrease
we're now five years into a period of
much slower costs decrease but
expectations in general remain unchanged
some people haven't noticed the change
some believe it's temporary and the
industry will return to the good old
days of forty percent Kreider rates
industry insiders are projecting no more
than twenty percent rates for the rest
of the decade technological and market
forces make it likely that as usual
they're being optimistic lower Kreider
rates greatly increase both the cost of
long-term storage and the uncertainty in
estimating it lower Kreider rates mean
that the economic service life of media
will be longer placing more emphasis on
lower running costs than unload purchase
cost this is particularly true since
bulk storage media and no longer a
common consumer product businesses a
better place to make this trade-off and
the idea that archived data can live on
long latency low bandwidth media is no
longer the case future archival storage
architectures must deliver adequate
performance to sustain data mining as
well as low-cost bundling computation
into the storage fabric is the way to do
this okay let's have questions
and I apologize for for reading the top
but I'm getting to the age where if I
don't do that I tend my mind tends to
wander and I lose the thread okay does
bundling computation and will the
storage mean that we're going to a more
distributed kind of system as opposed to
a data center kind of centralization
it's know you can do it a data center
scale but it's it's the problem is that
moving the data from where it's stored
to where you're going to compute it
involves a lot of costs and particularly
a lot of power I believe the current
data center technology the top of rank
switches and the rest of the networking
burn about twenty-five percent of the
total power so if you can move the query
to the data instead of moving the data
to the query you can save a lot of power
and you get higher parallelism this was
what the foreign paper was all about
they showed that you could build a
fabric with very small basically
cellphone cpus and flash that could do
key value pairs as fast as conventional
servers with two orders of magnitude
less power two orders of magnitude less
power is a big deal in the data center
business and the people like see micro
and so on who are trying to be following
that path and up ya SE a micro I I think
that's were they called and the the dawn
paper that we did was basically saying
well can we do that and we do that model
for storage where we've built very low
power processors small amount of flash
fan the queries out massively and so we
only get a small amount of data coming
back so we don't need very powerful
network and if you do that with very low
power and solid-state memories then
you've got each unit is something that
you can basically encapsulate in
so yeah major extremely robust and these
things can run anti entry protocols
between them autonomously and you see
that for example Seagate's kinetic
architecture where they're putting
intelligence in the drives and similar
kind of thing from Western Digital is
moving in this direction because it's
that there's so much data out there that
moving it to someplace else to compute
on it is just getting too it's just
taking too long and it's turning too
much power so need to spread the
computation out in the day in the
storage fabric I mean not all the
computation but the low-level parts of
the query processing next next question
so are there any magic technologies on
the horizon ID cubes of magic stuff I'm
I believe but that's what I'm so I've
had a rash of media requests for
interviews this week and so far they've
all been journalists latching on to the
idea that long-term storage is a big
problem and the answer to it is quasi
i'ma little media and I'm very skeptical
about quasi immortal media not because I
believe that it's impossible to build it
is clearly possible to build it people
are building very long live media right
now there are 50 year life allegedly 50
hit live DVD technologies there are
people building metal tape that they're
writing on with a laser and things like
this but they haven't actually have much
impact in the market and the reason is
that if you commit to a technology if
you commit to a mainstream mass storage
technology now you know that firstly
it's going to get better it may not get
better as fast as it used to but it's
going to get better and it doesn't need
to get better very fast for you to want
to rip the media out every 10 years or
so
replace them with something a lot more
cost-effective so there's one problem
and the other problem is that if you
commit to some weirdo technology that
you believe is is going to allow you to
write the data once and forget it then
50 years from now when you want to read
that stuff you call up this little
startup company which never got to be a
mass-market product and say oh um can't
find the reader for this thing can you
send us another one it's like not going
to happen right so if you commit to some
weird-ass technology like like come I
don't know like like metal metal tapes
or whatever guess they'll tell you look
you can read the tape with a microscope
and yes you can but that doesn't help
you because looking at a stretch of tape
with a microscope can get a few bits off
it it can't get a petabyte off it so you
need but the river you need the readers
for this thing and fifty years from now
because they never got to be a
mass-market product and so they never
made enough money to keep the company
alive they're not going to be around and
yes it's a very seductive idea that you
can find this magic technology right the
data to it forget it and automatically a
hundred years from now you can read it
and as I said this this ignores the fact
that media failures are only a very
small part of the problem of keeping bit
safe for the long haul and the magic
media doesn't so don't do anything for
all these other problems work that's
going up and down into resurrecting the
old NASA toot yeah now that's magical
stuff but that it does really doesn't
scale and and the the problems that
we're facing now are I mean a petabyte
just isn't that much data any longer and
and and and you know hand processing old
tapes and things like that is wonderful
I I think it's fabulous that they did it
but it doesn't address today's problems
yes so observation the world seven track
teams with a recovery ten years from now
when the Internet of Things all these
billions of devices out there
essentially going to see all the data
and write the first approximation all
the data zillions of miles from any data
center where is this process they are
going to be processing story well I I
think it's a bigger problem with the
Internet of Things which is that it's
going to be a total security catastrophe
and likely to cause societal collapse
long before it gets to that point but
it's actually right I mean doesn't mean
won't happen it just means we'll get
cyber war along with it yes which is
going to you have as likely to make the
other problems be fairly uninteresting
but anyway they still you know sue me
that there's only so long you've got the
same problem that they got at CERN which
is that the the detectors generate data
far faster than you can store it and so
you have to do online filtering of the
data before it gets anywhere close to a
storage medium simply to get the
bandwidth down enough that you can write
it and the Internet of Things is going
to have that problem and well it depends
on what you think the bandwidth from the
devices to something is because these
things are going to be talking over I
mean they're not going to have gigabit
fiber to your door switch or whatever
uh and yes there's going to be a
gazillion of them and they're going to
be sharing mr. no because the cost of
the costs of doing this don't because
the cost of doing this don't work out
the value of getting this bit from this
device to somewhere that it's got its
got to compete with all the other
devices for the limited resource of the
wireless network and so big yes but yes
but we we let me introduce you to the
cellular service in downtown Palo Alto
well they've it over the years it was
impossible to make phone calls from my
house which is a mile from downtown
Pardo until they put in cells on the top
of the poles great for about six months
now it's again impossible to make phone
calls from my house which is down a mile
from downtown Palo out in the heart of
Silicon Valley the phone companies are
going to want to make money deploying
that bandwidth and they're not going to
extract money from your your cat feeding
mechanism or something like that you it
there isn't the money to do it and so
that the extraction of the data is going
to happen really close to the devices
because you cannot fund getting it from
there anywhere else and this isn't
anything about technology it's not about
available bandwidth this is my money and
this is this is the problem that I have
with a lot of discussions of technology
is it's actually not about the
technology long-term preservation is not
about the technology we know how to do
it the problem is nobody's willing to
pay for it they're all do a branch
organizations
I have been occasionally I was actually
at the first talk that Stewart and Danny
Hillis gave about the the long now
foundation and I think that some of the
things they're doing a really
interesting in the sense of a kind of
like Cohen's ways of of presenting a new
in a very understandable way and I think
the clock is is fabulous I are it brings
up a whole set of really interesting
really long term things as in terms of
practical preservation for the next few
decades it's not the stuff that they're
doing is no interesting I that isn't
that isn't to say it's not worth doing
yeah well they have not found the
methodology the lg1 funding right to bed
yes okay you know if if you really want
to keep stuff for along the long haul we
know how to do it we make a lot of
copies of it we put it on Independent
Systems there that are different and the
best example I know about that this is
the British Library they have for data
centers around the country each data
center is the the nobody has
administrative access to more than one
data center they schedule updates to the
software so that each data center is
running different versions of the
software they're really careful about it
and and um I I imagine that they're
going to do a really good job of keeping
the data for a while but the British
Library is currently debating whether
the budget cuts are going to be twenty
five percent or forty percent so they
that data has risks that aren't that
aren't defended against by this this
this architecture
yeah it seems to me there's a big part
of this problem that nobody is working
on let's suppose you succeed in
preserving big bitter raised over a
thousand years I know I'm not interested
in a thousand years I would do I think
we're doing great if we we should be
doing no well the loss real and then we
have nothing more to say with each other
to each other the idea of talking about
preserving stuff for a thousand years is
it's fine for the long now foundation to
do it but it's not in the realm of
practical engineering the loss rate of
data from a thousand years ago is
effectively a hundred percent we have
almost no data from a thousand years ago
lots of stuff cut into stone the
solution is the total data generated a
thousand years ago survived to today
effectively zero so it's just not an
interesting problem sorry we're cutting
this discussion of we're cutting this
discussion of the gentleman behind you
had a question experience are do you
think moving to digital is a good idea I
mean I read an article and year ago so
they are like trying to digitize all the
Hollywood movies because they were they
have these analog tapes which like
initially it might be a linky cause
clear but if you just kind of it all you
need is a cold cold storage room you can
preserve it like for 100 years but when
you move fooling when you digitize it
initially cost per bit might be less but
later the maintenance costs and every
time after clearly you need to refresh
the Delta orly make different copies
from so the maintenance becomes like
more and more expensive so i can show
that it's not true the reason they're
digitizing that the content is because
this gives them many many more ways of
monetizing it so that they have a flow
of funds which can easily cover the
migration costs the technology data
movies stuff like that is just much more
valuable in in digital form than it is
on film
and so yes it's true that I actually
film is a longer live medium but discs
are a much more valuable medium because
they give you all sorts of ways of
monetizing this stuff that having it on
ur having the the negatives doesn't yeah
so there's another dimension you haven't
discussed yet which is useful software
to process this old theater yeah that's
actually something that I I've been I've
been arguing about for a long time so
this whole discussion started with a
paper an article in Scientific American
by Jeff Rothenberg who pointed out that
formats were decaying rapidly and media
was decaying rapidly and this was all
going to be a big problem and he was
absolutely right but he was writing just
about the time that the web started
taking off in 1995 and the effect of the
web taking off was to change the role of
formats of data from being a private
thing to a particular application to
being a publication medium effectively
formats that are widely used today our
network protocols and the thing we know
from long experience is that the hardest
thing in the world to change is a
network protocol so what I predicted a
long time ago and it has actually turned
out to be the case is that widely used
formats stopped going obsolete it's
actually you can look in there are
people who have web archives going back
to nineteen ninety-seven for example the
institut national audiovisual in paris
their role is to collect audio-visual
material for the french culture and so
right at the beginning of the web they
were out collecting audio-visual
material from 1997 and so on on the web
and you would expect that very early
audio-visual formats on the web would be
the ones that would go obsolete
immediately well they look through their
collection and they could not render
about 1 less than 1% of the material
that they've collected that they'd
collected right back from then we are
actually facing this problem in a way
that I didn't predict which is that
adobe has been incapable of keeping
flash adequately secure so that browsers
rd implementing flash not because they
can't render it not because there aren't
actually even fairly decent open-source
renderers for full flash but because
nobody wants to run it because running
it is too big a threat to your computer
and that is going to be an issue but
fortunately it's actually very easy to
these days to build to to build
environments in which when you try and
render some really old media from the
web you create a virtual machine and an
emulator and you run a old browser in
this virtual machine and and it has all
the vulnerabilities that the that were
traditional in those days but it's
reasonably safe because it's only
attacking the virtual machine and back
in those days it was the bat the malware
wasn't targeted at the virtual machine
now yes we do and the problem with that
is copyright it's actually making copies
of old software is actually a violation
of the DMCA unless you have permission
from the publisher and you can do it the
Internet Archive does it they have a
collection now I think thirty six
thousand pieces of old software and they
do it on the basis of the safe harbor
provisions in the DMCA which mean that
if somebody sends them a takedown notice
they have to take it down and that's
kind of a bit of a problem for long-term
preservation of important pieces of
software like old versions of Windows
and things like that
now there is actually a collection that
Stanford is involved in working with at
the National Institutes Stanton so
standards and technology which they run
on behalf the FBI called the National
software research library which is there
for forensics and one way of dealing
with this issue for at least for the US
would be for the NIST and the library of
congress to cooperate so that the NIST
collection became part of the copyright
deposit collection at the National at
the library of congress which means that
we which would mean that at least if you
were physically at the Library of
Congress you could access and run that
old software the problem of general
access to 20 old software is not a
technical issue at all it's clearly a
legal issue and the legal stuff is
incredibly hard to deal with anyone yeah
so okay so moving from storage up to the
format of the data that's it I'm curious
about is have the publishers of the
things that you're archiving been
willing to provide them in a format that
doesn't have like encryption where you
don't have the keys or basically some
form of DRM that just happens to go out
of style and doesn't work anymore
because the cloud servers have been
decommissioned nine years ago yeah like
the way that Windows 10 just made a
whole lot of games unplayable because
they remove the drm support from the
colonel and yes this is an issue this is
a this is not an issue for journals
ebooks things like that we routinely our
archive that stuff some of it under
conditions where we're not allowed to
give access to it but but it's it's
playable games are a much harder problem
and there may be a completely unsolvable
problem the drm aspects the Internet
Archive has worked through what's called
the section 108 process which is a
revision of the copyright mechanism that
happens every few years of the library
of the Copyright Office in the library
of congress and they have a exemption
for libraries and archives to break drm
under certain specific conditions
basically if the thing becomes
unplayable and you can't get a player in
a reasonable cost in the market then
then libraries and archives for the
purposes of preservation are allowed to
break drm but there's a very restrictive
exemption but yeah now drm and
encryption or a real problems in some
areas of preservation and that
particularly applies to games Stanford
there's in the library as a guy called
Henry Lowood who runs the game
preservation stuff in the library and he
is I mean we have one of the world's
experts on doing this right right on
campus and any other I think we're
running out of time so if I think we
have time for one more I'm the Lord John
this may be a little bit philosophical I
didn't understand how you would want to
have the ability to recall any piece of
data from the past but do you have a
sense of what fraction of all data
that's ever been saved will indeed ever
be looked at again for some useful
reason other than archiving or
transporting or using so this this is a
question that Ian Adams UC Santa Cruz
set out to address some years ago he got
access logs from a number of different
archives and what he saw was that the
overwhelming majority of accesses were
for integrity checking and migration and
that the small fraction that weren't
were very sparse and very hard they
didn't show any useful patterns that you
could cash on or anything like that the
problem is that this these logs were
from now a decade ago and that's
actually not the way people deal with
data any longer well the way they want
to do now is they want to say okay show
me all the things in your archive that
match this query and that's a very
different that requires a very different
storage architecture to answer those
questions and we don't have good logs to
analyze but the impression is that once
you allow people to do for example text
search across an archive that's
basically all they're going to do and
that requires even massive indexes and
so on it's notable for example that the
Internet Archive has been very very slow
to turn on text search and text search
only covers a small fraction of their
collection at the moment because doing
it over their entire 20 petabytes or so
would cost them a lot of money just to
get the the the infrastructure in place
it's not clear that that it's not clear
that Google is allowed to get a copy of
the stuff that the Internet Archive
collected because Google is trying to
monetize it and monetizing that the
stuff gets you into a different legal
environment I mean it's also I'm you
know the Internet Archive doesn't
actually want Google crawling there 20
petabytes of stuff for everything
everyday living in texts just I mean
their bandwidth is pretty impressive all
on its own
loan from google I mean Jason Scott of
the Internet Archive has started a
project because there are actually only
two copies of their collection one of
them is in the church in san francisco
and the other one is in a warehouse in
richmond and that's not great
geographical distribution considering
the proximity of the four lines and so
on so jason has started a project trying
to backup the internet archive and the
numbers that you need in order to do
this are really rather spectacular and
it's not at all clear that it's doable
it's certainly the Internet Archive
can't afford to to have a third copy
somewhere a long way away and at the
moment it would pass their budget the
two installations of the two degrees
beyond diametrically opposite sides of
the Earth's of these coronal mass
ejections come on fight that one person
that would be good yes that's the reason
why in our dark archive network we have
copies we have 12 copies scattered
around the world you know in Australia
and Hong Kong and Italy and so on yeah
it yes geographic distribution is really
a good idea and it gets really expensive
really quickly we gotta cut that foot it
doesn't know yeah
you